I didn't realize when I casually mentioned
this Monday and did a segment about victimhood
and council culture on Tuesday, that this
was going to continue blowing up to the degree
that it has.
We've already talked about the Dr Seuss fiasco
earlier on in the show, but now we have another
Republican who has found another way to portray
herself as the victim in a completely unhinged
and ludicrous way for the party of personal
responsibility.
The modern Republican Party seems to have
no trouble whatsoever finding other people
to blame for just about everything.
I'm talking now about Trumpy and Kuhnen Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Green, who gave a speech yesterday
in the House of Representatives where she
claimed that when she has to wait in line
to go through a metal detector to get into
the House chamber, that that is a form of
voter suppression.
Now, you're probably anticipating more of
an explanation from me about what she means.
There's no more.
This is what she said.
Take a listen to her ranting and raving yesterday.
Mr. Speaker, I rise in opposition to H.R.
one while we're talking about voter suppression
and long lines.
I'd like to point out that there's real voter
suppression that happens right here in Congress.
Many members of Congress have to stand in
long lines to enter the chamber, going through
metal detectors, emptying our pockets and
being treated very disrespectfully so that
Israel voter suppression.
And it's a shame that it happens right here
on the House floor.
Standing in line to vote is not voter suppression
is just part of the voting process.
Just like people stand in line to buy groceries
at the grocery store, long lines to go through
a metal detector to go into the House chamber
is a form of voter suppression.
Voter suppression and protecting Congress
from someone carrying a gun in the chamber
are not the same thing.
And in practice, you know, the the obvious
question here would be, you know, Marjorie,
to even plausibly accept what you're saying,
you would have to demonstrate that going through
the metal detector has caused you or some
of your colleagues to miss a vote in the House
of Representatives.
And of course, there's no evidence anybody
has missed a vote thanks to having to wait
a few minutes in line.
Now, to be fair, she is one of the most ignorant
people in Congress.
So it wouldn't come as a huge shock that she
may not understand the difference between
voter suppression and standing in line for
hours to vote and not even being sure if you'll
be allowed because somebody might have purged
you from the voter roll.
There's that.
And then there's her standing in line for
a few minutes to get into the House of Representatives
as one of the most privileged individuals
in the United States, a member of a one out
of 435 members of the House, and having to
just stand in line for a few minutes there.
And then she introduces this idea of standing
in line at the grocery store.
And by the way, if voting is like going for
groceries, you can now get groceries delivered.
So why shouldn't you be able to get a ballot
delivered, which she's against?
But we'll skip that layer of hypocrisy for
today because it's just another rabbit hole.
One other thing, though, about groceries.
If Marjorie Taylor Green did have to stand
in line for groceries for as long as some
people have to stand in line to vote due to
poll closures and understaffing of polling
places, you can be damn sure that Marjorie
Taylor Green would be demanding congressional
action immediately on grocery store lines.
There's no question about it.
It just hasn't affected her personally yet.
Now, I guess the sort of real question here
is, is Marjorie Taylor Green pretending not
to know the difference between these things
and playing dumb for her ignorant followers?
Or does she really not know?
I actually can't tell anymore with these people.
She also said that standing in line at the
House of Representatives is voter suppression.
But standing in line to vote is not voter
suppression.
So, like even the arguments she's making are
internally conflicting.
It's a complete and total mess.
She's a confused individual, painfully so.
And the crazy thing is her followers are even
more confused and they are the ones who fall
for this stuff.
And unless we make sure that we again, focus
in on Georgia in 20, 22, like we did in 2020,
she may get herself reelected.
There are there are concerns from Republicans
that she may be facing a bloodbath.
I would assume nothing.
Trump, if he's able to raise money for that
new PAC, that he has that new grift.
And uses the money to support Marjorie Taylor
Greene because she supports him, she may well
be able to get herself reelected.
And one of the main signals that I've been
looking to, one of the bellwethers I will
be looking to in twenty twenty two to signal
what the future of Trump ism may be is whether
the Trump of Trump being elected officials
Marjorie Taylor Greene, Madison, Katherine,
Lauren, Bobert and others, do they get reelected
in twenty twenty two?
If they do and they may, it will signal that
in all likelihood, Trump ism has much more
staying power than many of us would like to
believe.